você já se deram conta de como é
perversa a elegibilidade do ser
se não se
se deram conta que ele provavelmente
coisas são muito privilegiados porque
ser o que se é
não é algo dado na verdade a sociedade
essa amálgama cultural tão diversa mente
hipócrita
ela gera espere como organismo vivo
invisibilizar o padroniza tudo que
considera estranho
sinceramente eu não entendo porque que o
meu a foto é tão estranho para a
sociedade
quando foi que a marca irá um problema
eu não entendo quando era pequeno ouvi
essa frase que era um problema que eu
era afeminado demais feminino de mais
que a minha forma de agir na hora certa
para o mundo porque o meu afecto à falta
tanto vocês essa frase de que era um
problema ela continue quando na minha
mente por muito tempo ela ainda está no
meu subconsciente até hoje
eu lembro de quando eu tinha 14 anos
está sentado no banco de uma praça e
está pensando em formas em rotas de fuga
que eu faria que eu teria caso meus pais
descobrirem que eu era gay
14 anos eu não conseguia pensar na
possibilidade de ver nos olhos deles
a vergonha estampada no rosto deles já
passaram vergonha que eu tinha de mim
mesmo inclusive já pensei em desistir
talvez fosse uma possibilidade uma
redenção por eu ser tão errado
era o que eu sentia nada 70% das
crianças de toda a razão em algum
momento passar por algum tipo de
situação vexatória de discriminação no
colégio 40% dessas crianças vão pensar
ou até tentar suicídio em algum momento
são crianças que desde sempre questionam
a sua expressão de gênero que não se
vêem talvez no sexo imposto pela
sociedade
são crianças que talvez em algum momento
do colégio da escola não vão nem poder
ir ao banheiro porque foi no banheiro
dos meninos eles debatem se foi uma das
meninas elas não vão aceitar
afinal quem sou eu como vocês falam
sobre sexualidade gênero
uma família de vocês com as pessoas que
cercam vocês com as crianças vocês como
vocês falam sobre essa construção social
tão maluco que nos é imposta todos os
dias que pertence à caixas duas caixas
simples como mulher e tem que parecê e
pertencer e figurar esse papel de gênero
vocês falam sobre isso eu lembro que os
meus 18 anos quando eu fiz exatamente 18
anos uma pessoa muito próxima da minha
família falou o seguinte até ele
ele se tornou bem o menor eu lembro do
meu sentimento ouvindo isso que foram 2
totalmente opostos um deles o orgulho de
conseguir parecer de conseguir fingindo
algo que talvez não fosse talvez não
fosse totalmente eu não pelo menos o
homem considerado o homem na sociedade e
outro sentimento é um sentimento de
tristeza de ter que fingir ter que
guardar esconder na sociedade que
considera tudo que é feminino menor que
coloca cada vez que as masculinas em
detrimento das femininas que coloca o
feminino com um subjacente como pior
como menor e nossa sociedade que faz
isso a gente se questiona com relação ao
gênero tempo todo
essas crianças fazem isso o tempo todo
eu lembro que quando eu entro no mercado
de trabalho eu começo a me perguntar se
realmente eu deveria levar quem era pra
dentro desse ambiente
eu começo a me perguntar se faz sentido
sei quem é o senhor acaba deixando um
pouco de quem eu era todos os dias pra
trás quando entrava na sua empresa é ser
quem se é todo tempo requer muito
esforço
quando a gente não é aquilo que é certo
na sociedade
quando a gente não é aquilo que é dado
como correta
assim era que eu fiz isso durante muito
tempo no meu trabalho até que em um
momento
alguém pergunta felipe segue alcançado
demint cansado de fingir ser quem eu não
amo ou pelo menos rígido é algo que eu
não era tentar me encaixar na
normalidade da ópera normatividade de
todos os dias à qual não pertencia
eu digo sim eu sou as portas se fecham
neste momento começa a ser excluído de
vários projectos sistematicamente de
coisas que eram extremamente importante
pra mim
nossa empresa eu acabo sendo tirado de
coisas que faziam de projetos que faziam
com que eu soubesse que eu estava
fazendo alguma diferença alguma
diferença realidade do mundo e nesse
momento eu entrei em depressão
eu saio dessa empresa e começa a
entender que provavelmente se eu
entrasse em uma outra organização em
outra empresa e aconteceu exatamente a
mesma coisa
entraria nessa empresa cantaria fingir
que eu não era eu seria descoberto que
seria mandado embora
quando era adolescente a minha mãe
descobriu que era gay e antes dela falar
comigo na verdade toda mãe sabe é de
alguma forma provavelmente eu dei muitos
sinais também mas antes ela falar comigo
ela foi atrás de conhecimento ela foi
buscar informação ela passa alguns meses
tentando entender como falar comigo para
um dia chegar e dizer filho eu já sei eu
te amo tá tudo certo
o seu tamanho não se preocupa o que ela
fez mudou todo mundo da minha vida
o que ela fez de buscar conhecimento foi
um movimento por amor é um movimento de
afeto de coisas que uma coisa que poucas
pessoas fazem hoje em dia de deixar o
preconceito de lado deixar as formas
paradigma das formas de pensar de lado e
procurar entender aquilo que a gente não
entende o que é estranho pra gente
simone boa' falava que não a mulher
nasce mulher ela se torna mulher bom eu
também nasci homem me tornei homem eu
aprendi a me vestir como homem a falar
como homem a pertence a esse
sigma de ser homem a esconder os
sentimentos do mundo porque quem é o
homem todo homem que é homem tem que
esconder os sentimentos do mundo
eu acabei entendendo qual é o meu lugar
na sociedade entendam que eu deveria
fazer nesse processo de depressão que eu
saio dessa empresa entendo que fica
aconteceria de novo ea vida na verdade
ela coloca gente no caminho que a gente
precisa trilhar a gente só não sabe
disso
eu acabo conhecendo uma empresa que
entende um pouco ou pelo menos a meu ver
o que era adversário inclusão o que era
a inovação ea cabo e colocando um
processo seletivo para entrar na empresa
e quando eu entro nessa empresa eu
descubro que não só a diversidade não é
um problema o fato de eu sei quem eu era
não é um programa mas podia ser a
solução que na verdade a diversidade ela
gera inovação
ela gera resultados para a empresa e
para as pessoas
quando a gente pode ser que a gente
ambiente de trabalho a gente produz mais
a gente quer ficar nessa empresa que
quer ser mais inovador mais produtivo
quando eu sei quem eu sou faz sentido e
é válido
as minhas idéias acabam sendo válidas
também eu tenho mais vontade de
contribuir e foi aí que comecei a
entender que eu tinha um papel
significativo nesse caminho
eu comecei a trabalhar para que ninguém
passasse pelo que eu passei
nossa empresa que ninguém passasse por
esse processo de ter que esconder quem
se a e foi aí que começa a trabalhar só
com diversidade inclusão a entender o
que a inclusão no mundo que a gente vive
a entender quais são essas populações
o que é isso os matadores sociais
entendemos privilégios principalmente
falar de diversidade é mais do que nada
entendem os tripulantes
e foi aí que eu aprendi algumas lições
bem importantes que eu gostaria de
dividir com vocês hoje aqui
a primeira delas é o que é adversário
inclusão no ambiente corporativo
quando a gente fala do adversário
inclusão dentro de uma instituição
a primeira coisa é olhar para o lado e
se perguntar quem é que não está aqui é
olhar para as pessoas que estão em volta
de vocês
comparar com a população do nosso país
a população está fora da empresa
entender quais são as pessoas que não
fazem parte das empresas não fazem fazem
parte desse ambiente da instituição que
não fazem parte desse lugar aqui com a
gente quem são as pessoas que não estão
quando a gente começa a perguntar isso
quando a gente começa a entender quem
são as pessoas invisibilizados pela
sociedade que não fazem parte não tem
direito de ser e que sequer acabam
entrando no mercado de trabalho ou que
estão no mercado de trabalho mesmo assim
não podem ser que a relação que a gente
começa a entender que a diversidade ea
gente dá um próximo próximo próximo
passo
esse próximo passo é se perguntar por
que essas pessoas não estão porque essa
galera não entra nas instituições que
essas pessoas não estão aqui com a gente
porque só a maioria das pessoas que
estão aqui que são privilegiados por
estar em um espaço seguro um espaço de
poder
a gente pode falar assim só se as
pessoas estão aqui não há outras pessoas
que fazem parte da sociedade num país
onde 54 pessoa por cento das pessoas são
pessoas negras 51 por cento das pessoas
são mulheres mas só dez por cento das
mulheres são políticas
aliás desculpa só 10% dos políticos são
mulheres
noventa por cento das pessoas que
governam para resolver os nossos
problemas são homens
uma população de 51 por cento de
mulheres
só que realmente as pessoas que governam
por nós
conseguem fazer isso da melhor forma a
maioria do branco heterossexual se
gênero e vejam bem eu sou um homem
heterossexual se gênero e branco mesmo
sendo gay extremamente privilegiada e aí
eu tive a minha primeira lição que a
diversidade inclusão ela só acontece na
conversa com o desconforto é quando a
gente olha para fora olha para nós
mesmos ea gente entende quem a gente é
nesse mundo tão desigual
e aí eu tive a minha próxima edição que
na verdade eu entendi que todos nós
somos sintomas de uma estrutura
todos nós somos preconceituosos porque a
gente aprende a ser assim de alguma
forma existe uma estrutura social
preconceituosa muito bem intrincado
colonizado e colonizam ante que forma a
nossa cultura a nossa cultura precede a
nossa educação portanto nós somos
sintomas são os produtos educados das
estruturas que é preconceituoso que
colonizam ante que é racista e tudo mais
que a gente já sabe quando a gente
consegue olhar para as pessoas como os
sintomas e entende que na verdade
ninguém simplesmente quer ser
preconceituoso
a gente consegue ser menos combativo e
opera mais como ponte
se vocês puderem escolher se estiverem
privilégio como eu tenho de poder
escolher a forma de lutar sejam tons
trabalho do diálogo
falem com as pessoas e daí vem a próxima
lição que também é muito importante
inclua as pessoas que ainda não se deram
conta que são sintomas
a gente está passando por um momento
muito difícil no nosso mundo porque
basicamente muitos movimentos fascistas
conservadores têm voltado porque a gente
não fez o nosso dever de casa certo nós
não incluímos as pessoas que deveriam
ser incluídos que fazem parte do
problema é que talvez faça inclusive
movimento contrário à inclusão na
solução
isso é um grande problema se nós não
formos todos juntos e todas juntas
nossa evolução e ser mais inclusivo de
ter um mundo mais justo pra todo mundo
a gente não vai em algum momento a gente
vai dar espaço para trás e tem que fazer
tudo de novo e quando a gente não
conhece a nossa história a gente tende a
repetir nosso passado
o próximo passo e próximo ensinamento
que eu tive é a diversidade
as diferenças e isso é muito bonito ela
só se dá na adversidade a realidade só
se dará às diferenças
mas foi um pensador da linguagem tudo
que a gente conhece só acontece porque
uma coisa diferente da outra e
diversidade inclusão é assim para a
gente aprender a incluir primeiro a
gente tem que entender o que nos
diferencia entender as diferenças
entender a diversidade evidenciar as
diferenças mas provavelmente em algum
momento já se perguntaram porque existem
tantas caixinhas a pergunta que o tempo
todo mas que ele fique porque a gente
fala tanto de lgbt que ir porque a gente
chama de feminismo e machismo e porque
tem tantos nomes e tanto as caixinhas se
nós somos todos seres humanos são
pergunta que parece óbvio mas na verdade
isso também expressa muito privilégio
vou contar uma coisa pra vocês que eu
aprendi para quem é invisível
quem está desconectado da possibilidade
de ser uma palavra um nome é a diferença
entre existir e não existe para quem
nunca soube o que se há desde a infância
pra quem acha que é uma anomalia é um
problema desde a infância têm um nome
que considere que isso não é fora do
normal é algo natural passou a diferença
é simplesmente a possibilidade de
sobreviver e último ensinamento eu acho
que um dos mais importantes e acho que o
mais bonito ea linha conector de todos
os outros é que tudo acontece só pela
busca do conhecimento que as pessoas
tendem a dizer nossa muito fácil buscar
conhecimento é óbvio que a gente precisa
buscar conhecimento mas para buscar
realmente conhecimento e se conectar com
as pessoas e se conectar essa realidade
precisa estar em um papel em um plano de
humildade é entender que na verdade a
gente nunca vai ter empatia o suficiente
para entender o que a pessoa sente
entender que a empatia tem um limite é
extremamente importante mas mais do que
tem empatia extremamente importante nós
temos autoridade autoridade uma das
coisas mais bonitas que existem
autoridade e afetar e deixar-se afetado
pelo outro
a autoridade é entender o seu lugar de
fala é entender os seus privilégios e
buscar conhecimento na outra pessoa
entrou em que só ela pode falar por ela
mesma
só ela pode se tornar visível ao meu ver
mas eu preciso deixar eu quis saber que
eu não conheço a vivência dela e quando
a gente entende a importância da
alteridade a gente faz exatamente o que
a minha mãe fez um dia de buscar
conhecimento para conseguir se conectar
comigo pra realmente trabalhar num
processo de afeto no movimento de amor é
que a gente vai conseguir incluir todo
mundo como dizes que nós não a expressão
de afeto maior do que a busca pelo
conhecimento
eu concordo totalmente eu tenho a dizer
uma coisa mas não existe expressão de
afeto maior do que a busca pelo
conhecimento em direção às pessoas e é
só assim que a gente pode consegue
realmente incluir se conectar de novo e
tornar todo mundo visível a então quando
todo mundo existir como pessoa
um ambiente justo uma sociedade justa é
que a gente vai poder chamar todo mundo
de ser humano
obrigado